only for one reason I did nothing wrong
the only reason I had a perfect
conversation with the president of
Ukraine perfect had they seen that
conversation before they made up the
story they made up the story about that
comer had they seen it we wouldn't need
to be talking about it right now the
conversation has been perfect and for
that reason I have tremendous mr.
president mr. president mr. president
are you an exhaustive Department ago
after
yeah
so they started
[Music]
and I thought if something I read the
papers and I read it probably in greater
detail than you actually and I try and
sift out the fake news from the real
news but as you know there's been a
long-term look at look-see and it looks
like it's becoming very serious for what
I'm hearing investigate the
investigators whether it's struck and
page whether it's clapper and whether
it's Comey and all of these people
because terrible things went on for our
country and we have a great Attorney
General highly prestigious man a very
honorable man and they've been looking
at it for a long time I can't tell you
what's happening I will tell you this I
think you're gonna see a lot of really
bad things and a lot of people think
that and they know they have problems
because they were very dishonest and
again I leave it all up to the Attorney
General and I leave it all up to the
people that are working with the
Attorney General who I don't know but I
will say this I think you'll see things
that nobody would have believed this was
the worst hoax in the history of our
country and a lot of people say that the
phony deal on impeachment where I have a
perfect conversation perfect with the
president of Ukraine and they're using
that to a beat one of the most
successful presidents we're going to hit
another stock market hi we have the best
jobs report we have the best
unemployment numbers we have the best
employment more people working today of
the united states than ever before I've
rebuilt the military with strong we just
did a great thing in Syria where we're
getting our troops out we took over oil
a lot of great things are happening in
this country I will say this
anything ever happened with this phony
witch-hunt that the democrats are doing
to do nothing democrats I really believe
that you'd have a recession depression
the likes of which this country hasn't
seen now